Tom Curren covers the Patriots for NBC
Sports Boston he joins us now Tom Curren
what was your Halloween costume I was a
clown I'll send you a picture Mike wait
you were a clown you are a clown all
right Ralph Malph
what do you got for me about the New
England Patriots eight games in heading
into a tough fight against the Ravens on
Sunday night where do you have this team
in comparison to other Patriots teams
you've seen certainly when you add it up
to a hundred and have both sides of the
ball separated out the offense is
nowhere near in terms of potency what
it's been in the past and that's gonna
be the major concern because you know if
you like I said it added up to a hundred
you have a defense it's off creating you
know at 85 to 90% of the team's potency
you need the offense average average and
that's why you see that disconsolate Tom
Brady throughout the 2019 season now I
think there's a hoppiness
because he's very happy about Mohamed
Sanu but this team right now is a little
bit flawed they have plowed through the
first eight games of this schedule they
have covered most games they've been in
games where you barely have to watch the
second half but as you said this
five-game stretch of Casey Baltimore
Houston Dallas and Philadelphia is
really going to be a great period of
time for them to learn more about
themselves and to learn how legitimate
this defense is historically offensive
line coach Donte scar Nekia had some
fairly candid comments earlier this week
about the issues with the offensive line
he took responsibility for it now this
is a guy who's one of the great
offensive line coaches of all time
is this an overstatement by him or do
you see flaws with the offensive line
for the Patriots the whole thing's a
mess there their ability to get to the
second level and run the kinds of plays
was you know guys pulling
getting out to the edge making the
blocks they did in the past is gone
and it hurts not having Gronkowski it
hurts not having Dwayne Allen it hurts
not having David Andrews Jack Mason and
Marcus cannon have played a little bit
lower than they had in the past and
their left tackle is Marshall Newhouse
right now in for Isaiah win in for Trent
Brown so yeah it's disarray a lot of it
falls on Sonia Michele's feet or at his
feet because he's the running back but
there's myriad other reasons that they
can't run it really the protection of
Brady hasn't been great either
you mentioned Rob Gronkowski and he
recently spoke to the Toronto Sun about
the possibility of coming back he seems
to think the doors open for whenever he
would want to return this year next year
four years from now I'm not sure that it
stays open indefinitely but for this
year he made it clear that Robert Kraft
the owner of the team wants him to come
back he's got 32 days to easily waltz
back into the locker room and emerge
from the reserve retired list do you
think there's a chance could you put a
percentage in your mind on the
possibility that Gronk will return this
year I'd say less than 5% and I've been
saying that since August would you lie
he retired for a reason and the reason
was physical and mental abuse is
overstating it physical and mental
duress that he expressed concern about
throughout 2018 all the way through
right up into the Super Bowl and the
fact that really honestly and I know
that Gronk continues to Chum the water
on his own which is good for the brand
the good for crunking but to me I think
the inability of people within the
organization to take a face value what
he has said especially the reasons that
he is retired in the first place because
of the duress that he felt he was under
he is it's wrong it's you know Robert
Kraft to sit up on an NFL Network stage
on a Thursday night a few weeks
go and talk about Rob Gronkowski
returning when he knows the direst that
corn cow skis gone under since last year
and the reasons that he retired I think
is unfair meanwhile I say that and Gronk
is playing grab-ass
ten minutes later talking about a
possible return so it's good for his
brand to do that but I still think it's
acting as if Gronk doesn't have the
agency to make a decision on his own and
stick to it Josh Gordon was released
from injured reserve yesterday he'll
pass through waivers it was a surprise
when he was put on IR it was surprised
when the Patriots decided to move on
from him what went wrong with Josh
Gordon in the Patriots his ability to
get to things look and this is a murmur
and rumblings and everything else and I
want the kid to do great I think we all
do as an individual because he's working
hard at it but I think the team had some
trepidation once he wasn't as prompt and
punctual as he had been in the past as
his period of time when it was injured
went on you know there were occasions
where it was late to meetings I
understand there were occasions they
they had a hard time locating him so
that in dependability coupled with the
fact that he wasn't extremely productive
you know really when he was in there
they had Nikhil Harry coming back they
had just acquired Mohamed Sanu and I
think there was trepidation about okay
well if we're looking at this again do
we want to rely on him I think he had a
very short rope that he was dealing with
so again that is basically the
scuttlebutt here
no one's going on the record necessarily
and said Josh missed meeting XY and Z
what was late too XY and Z and that's
why it happened but all of us with our
kind of underground sources and this is
from the radio folks who are well
plugged into the team to other folks on
the beat have all kind of gotten the
indication yeah
he was showing signs of undependable 'ti
hey last one for you and then I got a
run ranked Vegas in order of likelihood
Tom Brady back with the Patriots in 2020
Tom Brady retired from football in 2020
or Tom Brady playing for another team in
2020
I'd go 1-2-3 him back him retired in
someplace else actually go won him back
to him someplace else
three him retired he wasn't asked for
that ability to be franchised to not be
franchised just to have it my best guest
Mike is the most likely scenario is they
don't get something done he goes out
like Dante Hightower Devin McCourty Matt
Slater Randy Moss back in the day did
and finds out what is out there and then
returns to the Patriots and they say
okay what could we do because I don't
think the Patriots are gonna give him a
significant raise over the 23 million
that he's making this year just out of
the goodness of their hearts because
he's about to be a free agent they're
gonna say go find out what's out there
and then we'll talk yeah and if the
objective is to continue to win Super
Bowls look he could make a lot more
money elsewhere but I think there's only
one place where the table continued to
be set year after year for him to pursue
championships and that's right where he
is all right Tom thanks as always for
some of your time enjoy the game Sunday
night we'll talk to you down the road
all right buddy good hearing from you
areas Tom Curren NBC Sports Boston
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports